please welcome your host mr. what a year
it has been improved front-facing
cameras made it so we could focus on the
important things in life more RAM made
it so we could scroll through those of
vital facebook posts just a little bit
faster and don't forget about that new
popular speaker hole design okay
so wasn't a revolutionary year in
smartphones but overall improvements to
the essentials mean that now most phones
are great and deciding on a phone is
harder than ever at this point between
cameras fingerprint sensors and screens
the best Android phones and the newest
iPhones are even on hardware what you're
really deciding between is operating
systems of course which OS is right for
you is an intense topic for another day
which brings us to our first category
the best iPhone and the winner is oh you
won't believe it the iPhone 6s upgrades
to the iPhone 6s is processor cameras
and overall build make it the best
iPhone you can buy and the best
all-around phone you can buy if you ask
me go for the 64 gigabyte version
seriously you'll be out of space in no
time with the 16 but if you want longer
battery life and better photos go for
the iPhone 6s plus just hope you have
big hands not everyone needs the newest
iPhone no I barely use the biggest new
feature the 3d touchscreen if you're
looking to save money just get last
year's iPhone 6 no one will even notice
johannah got the rose yo and Arjun with
I'm going to let you finish but Android
has the best smartphones of all time
security don't tase me bro
but yes the winner of the best Android
phone is wait we've got a tie the galaxy
s6 and the Nexus 6p Samsung's Galaxy s6
wins on design and camera
it took better photos than any Android
phone I tested however its software and
battery life are nowhere near as good as
the Nexus 6p the 6p has a bigger screen
google's clean version of android 6.0
and gets software updates faster than
other Android phones plus it starts at
just five hundred dollars one of the
best things about Android phones you can
get really good phones for way less than
$400 and the award for the best low cost
phone goes to the oneplus X between the
design camera and fast processor it's
amazing what you can get for $250 the
catch it can be really hard to find
that's why you're probably better off
spending a little bit more for the three
hundred and eighty dollar Nexus 5x don't
move we'll be back after this short
commercial break with the award for the
best stylus in a supporting role